اعلن حزب الله قصف قاعده ميرون
الاسرائيليه ب 62 صاروخا في اطار ما وصفه
بالرد الاولي على اختيال نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس صالح العاروري ورفاقه
واشار حزب الله الى ان قاعده ميرون تعتبر
مركز الاداره والمراقبه والتحكم الجوي
الوحيد في شمال اسرائيل وتشكل مركزا
لعمليات التشويش الالكتروني كما تدير
العمليات الجويه باتجاه سوريا لبنان
وتركيا وقبرص وشمال الحوض الشرقي للبحر
الابيض المتوسط كما اعلن الحزب استهدافه
موقع المطله وسكنه هنين الاسرائيليين وقال
الحزب ان احد مقاتليه استشهد في جنوب
لبنان وشنت الطائرات الاسرائيليه غاره على
محيط بلده عيت الشعب وقصفت مسيره بلده
يارون كما تعرض محيط بلدات الخيام وميس
الجبل وحوله وبليد ومح حبيب ومركبه ورب
وبرج الملوك لقصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ان سلاح
الجو استهدف مواقع لحزب الله ومنصات
صواريخ في بلدات يارون وراميه وعيت الشعب
جنوبي لبنان وكان المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد قال انهم رصدوا اطلاق نحو
40 صاروخا من لبنان باتجاه منطقه جبل
الجرمق في الجليل الاعلى وذكرت القناه الث
ع الاسرائيليه ان صفارات الانذار دوت في
94 بلده ومدينه على الحدود مع لبنان بينها
صفد وكرما اييل في الجليل من ناحيتها قالت
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان الجيش قرر اغلاق
كافه الطرق والشوارع على طول الحدود مع
لبنان ونقلت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
سلاح الجو بدا بشن سلسله هجمات في جنوب
لبنان ردا على اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه
اسرائيل ضرب السفر ينضم الينا من بلده
رميس جنوبي لبنان مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم كما تنضم الينا من الجليل الاعلى
مراسله الجزيره فاطمه خميسه ابدا معك مازن
التطورات متلاحقه في جنوب لبنان ضعنا في
صوره هذه
التطورات نعم في الواقع فدا بعد هذه
العمليه المركبه التي نفذها حزب الله صباح
اليوم واستهدفت هذه القاعده الجويه
الاسرائيليه حصلت مجموعه من ردود الفعل
الاسرائيليه من خلال القصف عبر المدفعيه
والقنابل الحارقه والطائرات الحربيه
والطائرات المسيره مجموعه كبيره من
البلدات اللبنانيه جرى استهدافها وحاليا
هنالك سؤال رئيسي يطرح هنا في لبنان هل ما
قام به حزب الله هي عمليه ناجزه وبالتالي
يكون قد انجز ما ما هدد به من رد على
اغتيال الشيخ صالح العاروري ام ان ثمه
عمليات اضافيه قد تحصل خلال الساعات
المقبله لا سما ان حزب الله من خلال بيانه
اشار الى ان هذه العمليه تعتبر ردا اوليا
العمليه المركبه التي نفذها الحزب تقرا
هنا على عده مستويات في لبنان على المستوى
العسكري المباشر على المستوى الامني وايضا
على المستوى الرمزي على المستوى العسكري
يمكن الحديث عن ان هذا الاستهداف ضمن عمق
يتجاوز 10 كيلومترات في داخل الاراضي
الاسرائيليه يعني بان حزب الله وسع من
رقعه الاستهدافات سابقا قصف كابري وقصف
ايليت وهي مناطق تبعد نحو 7 كيلومترات او
8 كيلومترات عن الحدود ولكن اليوم هنالك
توسيع لهذه الدائره وايضا على المستوى
العسكري استخدام هذا الكم الكبير من
الصواريخ له دلاله على المستوى الامني حزب
الله كان واضحا من خلال بيانه بان هذه
القاعده المستهدفه انما هي تقوم بالتشويش
وبادت العمليات على طول ساحل البحر الابيض
المتو موسط من لبنان مرورا بسوريا وصولا
الى تركيا وايضا قبرص وشمال حوض البحر
المتوسط اما على المستوى الرمزي وهنا له
دلاله بان عمليه اغتيال الشيخ صالح
العاروري ورفاقه تمت من خلال طائره حربيه
اسرائيليه اطلقت الصواريخ وبالتالي عندما
يختار حزب الله الهدف ويكون قاعده لاداره
العمليات العسكريه الجويه في لبنان وغيرها
في المنطقه من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فان هذا الاستهداف يعني ايضا
ببعده رمزي بان غرفه العمليات ضمن هذه
القاعده التي ادارت عمليه اغتيال الشيخ
صالح العاروري تم توجيه الصواريخ باتجاهها
ولكن ضمن هذه المعادله وهذه الابعاد هنالك
من يتحدث عن ان ربما حزب الله من خلال هذه
العمليه هو يسعى الى محاوله اعاده ترميم
القواعد التي خرقتها اسرائيل من خلال هذا
الاستهداف في عمق الضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه
وبالتالي قد يكتفي الحزب بعمليه اعاده
ترميم قواعد الاشتباك من خلال هذا التطوير
الاضافي بمعنى ان اي اغتيال في العمق
اللبناني سيقابله استهداف في العمق
الاسرائيلي ولكن بطبيعه الحال هنالك ايضا
من يطرح اسئله هل ان هذا الاستهداف بهذه
الطريقه سيعيد ترميم هذه القواعد لا سما
ان ما قامت به اسرائيل من خلال استهداف
الشيخ صالح العاروري في عمق الضاحيه
الجنوبيه بعث برسائل عديده وكسر خطوطا
حمراء كان قد رسمها حزب الله وبالتالي
الايام المقبله هي كفيله بتبيان هل سيكتفي
حزب الله بهذه العمليه عند هذا الحد ام ان
الامور ستاخذ منحنيات مختلفه لا سما بان
هنالك ضغطا غربيا امريكيا اليوم على لبنان
في محاوله لكبح جماح التصعيد وهذا ما
يحمله معه الموفد الامريكي هوكس الذي كان
قد وصل الى تل ابيب وكان يحمل رسائل وصلت
ايضا بالتواتر الى لبنان ودعوه الى تهدئه
الامور ومحاوله تطبيق القرار 1701 ولكن
الكلام كان واضحا بالامس من خلال ما اعلنه
الامين العام لحزب الله عندما قال بان
لبنان صحيح بانه يمكن له ان يحرر كامل
اراضيه وذلك في اشاره الى مزارع شبعه
تلالك فرشو والنقاط المتحفظ عليها على طول
الخط الازرق ولكنه اشار بان اي تفاوض او
اي حديث بالسياسه حول هذه المواضيع لا
يمكن ان يتم دون وقف القتال ووقف العدوان
الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه وبالتالي الرساله
التي اوصلها حزب الله ضمن هذا الاطار والى
وردا على كل تلك الرسائل الغربيه بعجاله
فد هي تشير الى ان الاولويه وقف الحرب
العضوان الاسرائيلي على غزه ومن بعدها
يمكن الحديث عن كل التطورات ومن هنا تاتي
هذه العمليه بهذا النسق من الهجوم الذي
نفذه حزب الله وكما اشرت الرسائل الان
وايضا الاسئله تتمحور هل سيكتفي حزب الله
بهذه العمليه ام ان مقبل الايام ومقبل
الساعات سيحمل عمليات اضافيه